The Mexican government says Texas
officials told it a dead body was found
snared on these buoys in the Rio Grande
river near Eagle Pass Texas on Wednesday
afternoon authorities don't know whether
the person died on the buoy or someplace
further up River and floated Downstream
whatever the final determination might
be the buoys are the latest addition to
an elaborate series of obstacles in and
along the river they are part of a
years-long multi-billion dollar effort
by Texas Republican Governor Greg Abbott
to stop migrants a job Abbott says the
Biden Administration has failed to do
but former Eagle Pass mayor Pepe Aranda
says it's all a political stunt it's all
a stage it's all a theater to be able to
say hey we did something as we watched
groups of migrants cross the river
seemingly unbothered by the buoys and
fencing the U.S justice department has
sued Texas calling the river barrier a
threat to Public Safety and demanding it
be removed Governor Abbott responded
dismissively with a letter to President
Joe Biden saying see you in court
the issue has divided people here some
say the governor has gone too far others
say the town is under siege if you don't
have barricades there to stop them
they're going to be swarming all over
the community
and I live in this community
at the mission border hope migrant
shelter a busload of people files in out
of the blistering midday heat
director Valeria wheeler gives them a
quick orientation they feel humiliated
and
they don't know what to expect anymore
because
they feel like criminals the people here
include young children nursing mothers
babies and diapers nineteen-year-old
Alison Jimenez seven months pregnant is
from Honduras she says her River
Crossing was terrifying razor wire cut
her leg
I was scared because I thought even if I
don't die something could happen in the
river like I could drown or hurt myself
she has no money no relatives in the U.S
and no idea what to do next but at least
she and the others here are alive Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera Eagle Pass Texas